just the fact that asian women had  slightly higher incomes than white men  was just  it was shattering to this narrative that  that race  and gender determines your success and  so i did some digging i talked to some  experts and  i looked into the studies there are a  lot of cultural patterns that  asian women have such extraordinary  outcomes  economically and education wise so  among all women asian women are most  likely to  major in high earning fields such as  stem  they're more likely to be married when  they have their kids  and they tend to have kids a bit later  and they tend to have more  family support in raising their kids  that's interesting yeah  but the left just seems to completely  avoid these  explanations for success in our society  the implication would be that its  culture its family its values that  determine success  not your white privilege not your male  privilege  not being straight